hey guys welcome back to brain Nevada
we're back on outer worlds today and I'm
gonna try to keep this introduction very
brief so I can under it so I can
basically explain what the hell is going
on with today's video basically this is
going to be showing off the endings the
four separate endings for the companion
characters within outer world so if you
are unaware of course our six companions
in the game and each of them have their
own quest progression that you can do
and upgrade them and then you can kind
of fulfill their thing kind of like Mass
Effect in a sense if you've played that
well depending on what side you choose
end as well if you actually happen to
progress with them their quest they get
a different ending at the end so I'm
going to be showing them in this order
it's going to be phineas and then the
uncompleted meaning I did none of their
quests fini
then Phineas with the completed side
board uncompleted and then board
completed they'll be in the description
down below as well if you want to browse
through those all I'm gonna be showing
is the ending cutscene of those likes
little sections nothing else in regards
to the main story so no spoilers besides
a companion stuff there's always like to
be if you're doing just obscure before
new let me know your favorite ending in
the comments below and hope you enjoy le
savored her adventures on the unreliable
once they were done she returned to life
as usual running missions of dubious
legality shunning respectable work and
living life to the fullest she meant to
reach out to her one-time captain but
she was always bad at keeping in touch
life in Halcyon was sobering for Felix
milestone the grand revolution he
dreamed of never came there was no great
awakening for the colony no celebrations
in the streets there was only the hard
desperate work of trying to repair a
broken colony
Felix never had a head for numbers but
if there was labor to be done he was
there to help
eventually Felix realized that the work
of a revolution was done with two hands
after all he'd seen and heard
adventuring with you The Vicar
Maximilian de Soto renounced his faith
and joined the effort to rebuild the
colony ironically he finally found the
joy that had eluded him over the course
of his life and realized that perhaps he
was always meant to be just a simple
laborer after all he quickly dismissed
the idea
though Parvati eventually grew
comfortable aboard the unreliable she
never quite came out of her shell she
seemed to prefer the company of ADA to
the crew and she could often be found
neck deep in cables and grease telling
ADA funny stories from her childhood
while the colony fell into chaos she
found an island of relative peace with
Ada and they formed an unusual bond she
decided to remain aboard the unreliable
permanently as its chief and sole
engineer as hard as she tried to drink
them away
yokas memories eventually overcame her
traveling with a crew served as a
constant reminder of the family she'd
lost and so she eventually returned to
mana to get back to what she found most
comfortable the deep end of a bottle and
the far end of a trail few have seen her
since but travelers often swear they
hear her and her machine gun in the
night screaming swears and spitting
bullets before his untimely death
captain Alex Hawthorne had plans to
restore and modify for combat purposes a
sanitation and maintenance auto
mechanical but he found in the state of
disrepair in Emerald vales scrap yard
that unit remains broken down and
forgotten in the unreliable supply
closet to this day your influence
shifted Ellie's perspective she finally
admitted albeit grudgingly that she just
might need other people sometimes with a
steady income from the life insurance
payouts she was finally able to afford a
ship of her own she hired a small crew
and flew supply missions to communities
on the fringe some of them were even
legal life in Halcyon was sobering for
Felix millstone the grand revolution he
dreamed of never came there was no great
awakening for the colony no celebrations
in the
there was only the hard desperate work
of trying to repair a broken colony
Felix never had a head for numbers but
if there was labour to be done he was
there to help eventually feel it's
realized that the work of a revolution
was done with two hands as much as he
enjoyed his adventures aboard the
unreliable the vicar known as machs
eventually decided that it was time to
move on to live out the life he had
sought so long to create he knew there
were many in the colony who carried
burdens much worse than the ones he had
struggled with and he devoted himself to
easing their suffering wherever he could
he only ever took up arms again to
defend the defenseless unshackled from a
lifetime of striving and fighting the
universe and himself vicar Maximilian de
Soto was finally at peace once the
matter was the hope colonists was
resolved June lay bashfully asked
Parvati if she'd like to join her
permanently on the ground breaker and
Parvati enthusiastically if somewhat
awkwardly agreed the stories of her
adventures spread across the colony and
Parvati soon found herself the center of
attention
having served as the engineer of a
renowned space craft [ __ ] freighters
and wildcat miners sought her out by
name and in no time she was a fixture in
the ground breakers mechanical ecosystem
she and June Leigh were never far apart
Nyoka returned to monarch to take
another crack at making a permanent life
for herself she formed the Terran group
an MSI subsidiary of ragtag survivalists
and wilderness experts anyone in need of
a guide or just looking to throw back a
beer and swap stories could find her
camping on the trail or clearing an
infestation the Sam unit that
accompanied you spread awareness of the
product line superior sanitation and
maintenance capabilities across what was
left of the colony this led to a boost
in Sam unit sales did you know that Sam
units are the longest lasting toughest
acting cleaning solution in ASEAN Elly
savored her adventures on the unreliable
once they were done she returned to life
as usual running missions of dubious
legality shunning respectable work and
living life to the fullest she meant to
reach out to her one-time captain but
she was always bad at keeping in touch
as the board reasserted control over
Halcyon Felix came to realize that his
life as an upstart rebel had come to an
end the board's victory crushed any hope
for a grand revolution across ASEAN and
so Felix once again found himself
without a purpose in life
and so disillusioned with his former
boss and with nowhere left to go
Felix left his crew without saying
goodbye he was never heard from again as
a reward for his part in her courageous
rescue the adjutant invited the vicar
known as max they become one of the
leaders of the order of scientific
inquiry max eventually rose to the top
becoming the presiding bishop of the OSI
he denounced his spiritual meanderings
as a misguided attempt to come to terms
with his long dead parents his only
regret was that they had not lived long
enough to see that he was right all
along though Parvati eventually grew
comfortable aboard the unreliable she
never quite came out of her shell she
seemed to prefer the company of ADA to
the crew and she could often be found
neck deep in cables and grease telling
Ada funny stories from her childhood as
the board began to roll out their
lifetime employment programme Parvati
was plagued by dreams of freezing to
death she began taking increasingly
longer Shirley's and she eventually
disappeared from the unreliable entirely
the board never knew what became of her
and under the adjutant's orders they
never tried to find out Parvati was
afforded a measure of peace and left to
her own devices as hard as she tried to
drink them away
yokas memories eventually overcame her
traveling with a crew served as a
constant reminder of the family she'd
lost and so she eventually returned to
mana to get back to what she found most
comfortable the deep end of a bottle and
the far end of a trail few have seen her
since but travelers often swear they
hear her and her machine gun in the
night
screaming swears and spitting bullets
before his untimely death captain Alex
Hoffman had plans to restore and modify
for combat purposes a sanitation and
maintenance auto mechanical but he'd
found in the state of disrepair in
Emerald vales scrap yard that unit
remains broken down and forgotten in the
unreliable supply closet to this day
your influence shifted Elly's
perspective she finally admitted albeit
grudgingly that she just might need
other people sometimes with a steady
income from the life insurance payouts
she was finally able to afford a ship of
her own she hired a small crew and flew
supply missions to communities on the
fringe some of them were even legal
as the board reasserted control over
house young Felix came to realize that
his life as an upstart rebel had come to
an end the board's victory crushed any
hope for a grand revolution across
Halcyon and so Felix once again found
himself without a purpose in life and so
disillusioned with his former boss and
with nowhere left to go
Felix left his crew without saying
goodbye he was never heard from again
as a reward for his part in her
courageous rescue the adjutant invited
the vicar known as max to become one of
the leaders of the order of scientific
inquiry but max had no interest in
serving any organization let alone the
OSI which he knew would never tolerate
his heretical theories instead he
attempted to minister to the people of
Byzantium they rejected his ideas being
far too satisfied with their own
material comforts disillusioned max gave
up and left the city he was never heard
from again once the matter with the hope
colonists was resolved June lay
bashfully asked Parvati if she'd like to
join her permanently on the ground
breaker and Parvati enthusiastically if
somewhat awkwardly agreed as the board
began to roll out the lifetime
employment program
Parvati was increasingly plagued by
dreams of freezing to death and rarely
left their shared quarters stymied by
dwindling resources June lay struggled
to keep the groundbreaker afloat their
relationship couldn't survive the strain
Parvati moved into crew quarters and
found work servicing water pumps in
hydroponics Nyoka returned to monarch to
take another crack at making a permanent
life for herself she formed the Karen
and MSI subsidiary of ragtag
survivalists and wilderness experts
anyone in need of a guide or just
looking to throw back a beer and swap
stories could find her camping on the
trail or clearing an infestation the Sam
unit that accompanied you spread
awareness of the product lines superior
sanitation and maintenance capabilities
across what was left of the colony this
led to a boost in Sam unit sale